[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 23rd
episode of my chest trap series in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful high profile trap in the BOGO
Indian from the black perspective the
opening arises after the following model
d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6 and many white
players hate to play against
nimzo-indian so the other option white
is having here is Knight to f3
completely avoiding nimzo-indian theory
well guess what we are going to play
Bishop to b4 check anyways and enter
into the BOGO Indian territory now here
if I continue with Knight to c3 then the
position will be transposed into the
nimzo-indian so accordingly there are
two based joys here for the white either
Bishop to d2 or Knight B to d2 we are
going to concentrate on the move Bishop
to d2 which in fact highest Lee played
mu in this position and against this
black will continue with Queen to e7 so
supporting the bishop and we reach to
the critical position where if you check
this position in online database you
will find out that g3 has been highest
Lee played mu apart from any other
mousse and in fact it is a logical move
because after the move g3 white simply
wants to play Bishop to g2 and quickly
castle on the Kings side where he has a
good space in the center no matter we
are going to play Knight to c6 and once
again village to the crossroad where
White has two major choices either to
play Knight to c3 or the move Bishop to
g2 in this video we are going to consume
straight on the move Bishop to g2
however if you open in place Knight to
c3 then I have attached a sample line in
the PGN which will give you a very good
idea how to play such a position okay
Bishop to g2 and now comes a very
important move black should take this
bishop and the trap is set right here as
you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows White has two major choices
amongst them only one option is right
can you guess the right choice well if
you choose the move Queen captures d2
then congratulations you straightaway
enter into the BOGO Indian trap aha
yes right so this is a completely wrong
move which many times happen and if you
check this position in online database
you will find out that there are more
than 300 games played from this position
including some vault loss grandmasters
now before we look at Queen to d2 and
the trap there is one important point I
like to highlight here that after the
move Knight B to d2 we can simply
continue with d6 ePHI and black get a
very reasonable game for example a
sample line can goes like this
d6 castle on the kingside castle on the
kingside efore and now the stomata came
in the center ePHI which gives gate game
to the black and as after the main line
moved defy black and simply drop back
the night to the BH square and later on
the night can be reroute to the good
square C Phi and the position resemble
one of the Kings Indian variation where
dark square bishop has been exchanged I
have attached a model game where a 2600
GM simply crushed at 2400 GM in 23 moves
so kindly go through it
now let's see what happens if you open
and continue with Queen captures d2
which is more natural as White Knight
wants to go to the c3 square but the
problem with this movie is after the
move Knight to e4 however white plays he
get a lost position the Queen has been
attacked more than 90 percent of the
game continues with Queen to c2 which in
fact as per the engine base mu in this
position but now comes this lethal check
which completely shattered winning dream
for the white camper
well if white continues with came to
have fun then this rook will not see a
daylight for a while so obviously let's
see what happens if I try to block the
check the first more I want to consider
is Knight f2 d2 which a kind of logical
vu as what is unleashing the attack to
the e4 Knight but now you will see the
important of playing the move Knight to
c6 as black and simply capture on d4 and
the best move here for the white is to
play Queen to 7 and except that he lost
upon for nothing in one online blitz
game my opponent continues with Queen
captures evil which at first sight looks
so tempting but after the move Queen
captures b2 it is very obvious that
white is going to lose in exchange just
within 10 moves of the game if Knight to
c3 the night to see to check is a very
strong reply so in the game my opponent
continues with castle on the Kings side
but after Queen captures even there is
no way if I can trap that Queen on even
as Queen can easily come out and no
matter however white plays with accurate
play black should win this game
the second more I want to consider is
Knight B to d2 which in fact look more
natural in this position but after
Knight captures d2 white is having a
great difficulty as he simply cannot
capture this knight with his own night
as the default born hangs and if he
continued with Queen captures d2 then
black can simply capture on c4 and
emerge with an extra pawn last but not
least what happens if white continues
with Knight to c3 well here the obvious
choice is
you should capture on c3 and white has
to capture with the Queen otherwise the
c4 pawn will drop so Queen captures c3
and after Queen captures c3 and B
capture c3 this time around black is not
upon up but this double pawn is almost a
great disaster for the white as black
and easily exploit in the middle game
where on the counter part white doesn't
have any weaknesses to attack now in
case if you don't know how to exploit
this weaknesses let me show you a simple
line that should start with the move d6
controlling the C Phi Square and after
the obvious move castle we should
immediately get out of that long
diagonal with rook to b8 black simple
idea is to target the c4 pawn so let's
say after the move rook to b1 we can
immediately attack the seafood with
Knight to e5 and after the only move
Knight to d2 we can play the move b6 and
as you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows Bishop to a6 is coming very
quickly and after that white will have a
very hard time to defend c4 pawn just to
highlight how quickly this c4 pawn can
be vanished
if white continues with the natural
moves such as e3 then we can play the
move Bishop to a6 attacking twice once
before and after the only response
looked to be for black has this star Moo
yup it's defy exploiting the pain and
winning the porn in a broad daylight
that's it guys I hope you learn and
enjoy this wonderful trap in the BOGO
Indian remember that if your opponent
continues with Queen captures d2 then
punish him with this model Knight to e4
Queen to c2 and this lethal check which
in fact in all the lines gives black a
great winning chances thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I'll meet you
in my next episode very soon bye and
take care
you